it begins
I might say my from ethics guide for
wife this week we look at cataclysmic
annihilation via an iPad as you might
expect from the title in the new
biblical epic Noah filmmakers needed
quite a lot of rain and water in fact as
it turns out in terms of man handling
water and rain over a crowd of people
it's one of the largest of its type ever
done as oscar-winning special effects
expert Bert Dalton told us the old adage
for filming special effects is front
light snow and back light rain this is
because unless rain is backlit it's very
hard to read on camera the team a to
produce rain effects to cover an outdoor
set about the size of two football
fields and they quickly realized that
they needed to do this by shooting night
for day since if they were to shoot
during the day they would have the Sun
constantly moving in
they'd never consistently he'd be able
to back like the rain but lining up a
couple of football fields with a
torrential deluge isn't that simple the
solution was to build a huge light and
rain rig on three three hundred ton
cranes hanging from each of the cranes
was a vast set of rain bars each which
were about a hundred feet by 40 feet
wide and on top of those were placed
massive balloons
space lights you know those are really
big nozzles that firemen have on the end
of their fire hoses but they had about a
hundred of them up in the air
the system rained out about 5,000
gallons a minute from these huge arrays
using two different types of rain
sprinklers one called a goose drowner
which is the big one that produces big
droplets and much smaller mist
sprinklers that were set up in between
there were 3,000 feet of 12 inch pipe
that was run from hundred thousand
gallon tanks through giant manifolds
backed up by two huge 12-inch pumps that
managed to provide a hundred and fifty
PSI over the hundreds of feet of pipe
hanging up in the air over the heads of
about five hundred screaming extras and
all of this was controlled by the iPad
the iPad allowed the team to always
correctly like the rain each individual
rain head has its own solenoid so if the
team wants to write out the background
they can turn on and run just the mist
heads at the back if they want pouring
rain they can run those really big goose
trainers and of course it's easy to turn
everything on but it's just as easy to
isolate
one area and keep it dry or from the
power of this custom iPad app each night
the team raised the rig up they used
about a hundred thousand to two hundred
thousand gallons of water which is well
over a million gallons of the equivalent
of about two Olympic sized swimming
pools dumped on the side over the 15
nights of shooting in the end the whole
scene had a massive water simulation
digitally added by ILM to complete the
sequence well don't forget to subscribe
for more behind the scenes action I'm
Mike Seymour for wide
you